[Music]
welcome back to harbor unbox today we
are finally checking out the asou ROG
Strix
rx 5700 XD graphics card bit of a
mouthful that one but it is an ROG Strix
graphics cards so yeah it is what it is
anyway I think we'll jump straight into
looking at the card and seeing what it's
all about for those of you who are
familiar with strict scrofa cards then
this 5700 xt model it's not really gonna
offer up any surprises pretty typical
Strix graphics card he adds very similar
to that massive gtx 660ti card that we
looked a little while ago didn't really
make much sense because it was a
high-end gtx 660ti if there is such a
thing but anyway we now have a high-end
rx 5700 XT so try a new Strix cooler
latest and greatest model has the new
axial tech fans
today's video is sponsored by Corsair in
the new hydro ax series if you came to
get into custom liquid cooling but you
don't know where to start check out
their custom cooling configurator now
this is a useful tool for even
experienced builders the interactive and
intuitive configurator allows you to
visualize how the impact will look and
most important of all allow you to
quickly and easily work out all the
cooling bit you'll need to make your
ultimate gaming PC for more information
please check the link in the video
description the card itself measures 305
millimeters long 130 millimeters tall
and 54 millimeters wide making it a very
long and tall triple slot card that
being the case you probably won't be
surprised to hear that it weighs in at a
rather hefty one thousand four hundred
and fifty three grams and that actually
makes it the heaviest 5,700 XD graphics
card that we've seen so far beating even
the MSI gaming X model by around 40
grams around on the back side of the
card we find a full length back plate
and again this is the typical version
that you'll find on a strict graphics
card however unlike the previous
versions that we've already looked at
such as the RT X xx 80 TI Strix this
radio model makes better use of the
backplate by turning into a heat
spreader with a number of strategically
placed thermal pads taking the cooler
off for a better look we've
a massive heatsink that weighs in at 845
grams with the plastic shroud removed
for context to the MSI gaming X heatsink
tip the scales at 780 grams 694 grams
for power colors red devil and just 483
grams for sapphires Nitro+ that means
you're essentially getting 75% more
metal with the Strix version when
compared to the Sapphire Nitro+ now this
isn't just a big heavy heatsink it's
actually quite well designed and it
features a large nickel plated copper
baseplate that feeds into half-a-dozen
nickel-plated 6 millimeter copper heat
pipes a sous has also done an excellent
job by maximizing fin density with some
interestingly placed heat pipes but it's
a really cool design and they've crammed
many fins as they possibly can into it
and the vrm is also cooled using an
aluminium base plate which connects to
the main heatsink though interestingly
it only extracts heat from the power
stages and not the alloyed chokes now
moving on over to the PCB we find an
interesting heat spreader / structural
support that's designed to not just cool
the GDD r6 memory but also stop the card
bending under the weight of that
absolutely massive heatsink that we just
looked at as soos has created small
ripple strips over the key components to
maximize surface area for increased
thermal dissipation it's an impressive
looking design so I'm keen to see how
well it works
now with the reinforcing bracket removed
we get a good look at the naked PCB and
here we find 8 micron G DDR 6 memory
chips along with a 10 plus three-phase
VRM has to be said power delivery on
this card is extreme overkill but
hopefully we see some very low vrm
operating temperatures given the
overkill vrm design you won't be
surprised to hear a soos is using a pair
of 8 pin PCIe power connectors to feed
power into the graphics card then
finally around the i/o panel we have a
standard configuration 3 display ports
and a single HDMI output oh and the i/o
panel has been powder-coated black which
looks pretty cool anyway enough going
over the card time to put it to the test
to do this I fired up f1 2019 and run
our loop for an hour we saw the Strix
peak at a surprisingly high 77 degrees
in a 21 degree room inside the course
Christel 570 X fully populated with
120-millimeter fans I'll compare this to
the other 5700 XTS tested later in the
video but with most running around 7 to
10 degrees cooler it is a surprisingly
poor result worse still the three fans
spun at 1900 rpm which makes the 77
degree low-temperature all the more
puzzling for example models such as the
Nitro plus and red devil ran cooler with
much lower fan speeds this is strange
but there is a clue as to why the Strix
runs so much hotter than expected and
it's to do with the GPU power draw here
we see the strict sucking down around
220 watts in this test whereas the red
devil in the same test only consumed
around a hundred and seventy watts so
that means the Strix is using almost 30%
more power now manually overclocked we
again saw a peak operating temperature
of 77 degrees but this time the fans
were spinning at 2200 rpm and it was now
quite easy to hear them over the case
fans also while we are targeting a core
frequency of 2150 megahertz
the card maintained a clock speed of
around 2 gigahertz so that's a mere 8%
increase in frequency from stock and the
GDD are 6 memory has a frequency cap of
950 megahertz and this was the frequency
that we were able to run it up as usual
with our graphics card reviews the focus
is on operating temperatures volume
power consumption and overclocking but
we'll also touch on out-of-the-box
performance as well as a manual
overclock in a few games there's really
no need to benchmark our entire games
library the test system uses an Intel
Core i 990 ok processor clocked at 5
gigahertz and we have 16 gigabytes of
ddr4 3400 memory
ok so let's quickly blast through these
game benchmarks as they don't really
tell us much other than their sous ROG
Strix RX 5700 XT performs much like any
other Radeon rx 5700 XT and we see
exactly that in Assassin's Creed Odyssey
Forza horizon 4
yeah much are the same here out of the
box to your sous tricks modelers like
any other factory overclocked 5700 XT
and that MANET was just 2% faster than
the AMD reference model wrapping up the
gaming benchmarks we see when testing
the shell of the Tomb Raider that the
Strix model saw a mere 5 percent
performance uplift from our manual
overclock
as we hit 95 FPS on average as noted
earlier the problem with the Strix
appears to be its hunger for power out
of the box the GPU consumed more power
than the gigabyte gaming OC version when
manually overclocked when compared to
the AMD of reference model we're looking
at a whopping 26 percent increase in GPU
power draw and 13 percent more than the
red devil though we did see an f1 2019
that it was almost 30 percent more so it
will depend on the game used naturally
this also impacts total system draw and
here we see like as rocks Taichi the
Strix really bumps up the total system
consumption and because of this extra
power drove the Strix runs much hotter
and louder than it really ought to
really you'd expect this model to match
MSI's gaming excellen-- 270 degrees but
instead it's running almost 10 degrees
hotter vrm temperatures suffered as well
in fact the massive overkill variant on
the Strix runs hotter than the reference
design of course it's having to deal
with considerably more load but this is
how it works out of the box the GDD are
6 memory temperature is also very high
82 degrees at least relative to other
high-end models from sapphire MSI and
power color for example now you could
forgive poor thermal performance if the
card was quiet but at 45 decibels it's
not exactly silent there are much louder
models but there's also cooler and
quieter models as well such as the power
color red devil the gaming X and a nitro
plus it's fair to say these soos ROG
Strix rx 5700 XT hasn't really impressed
me like I thought it would and for those
of you wondering I did try out the quiet
bias mode but it only reduced the power
consumption of the card by around 10 to
15 watts and with a 200 rpm lower fan
speed due to the reduction in power
consumption the peak operating
temperature for the GPU actually went up
82 degrees and then we also saw a
similar thing for the VR M&G DDR six
memory temperatures they also increased
by 6 degrees so again not a good result
the Strix 5700 XT just consumes way too
much power
even with a negative 20% power target
the GPU still hits 70 degrees with a fan
speed of 1300 rpm and while that does
put it on path or a devil
moment was slightly lower that we're
only talking about 1 to 2 FPS here
really though the strict seems to suffer
the same fate as as rocks Taichi both
are too aggressively tuned out of the
box which kills efficiency of the Navi
GPU and while both coolers are very
capable they're at a disadvantage when
compared to the competition the gaming
OC is a really good example of how to
tune the 5700 XT out of the box with a
very modest cooler gigabyte were able to
achieve excellent results by keeping
power consumption in check but it's not
just power consumption that's a problem
for a soos here like as rock their MSRP
is way off base four hundred and sixty
dollars us is just too much for a 5700
XT at that point you really are without
question better off getting a geforce
r-tx 2070 super for those of you
wondering I'd say four hundred and fifty
dollars is the cutoff but four hundred
and forty dollars or less is obviously
preferable at the end of the day the
Strix is a very high quality 5700 XT
it's just tuned way to aggressively out
of the box and it's heavily overpriced
I'd much prefer to see an emphasis on
efficiency rather than chart-topping
performance because this model really
could run considerably cooler and
quieter we'll only dropping one to two
fps and you're obviously not going to
notice I wanted to FPS drop and
performance but you will notice the card
running it much quieter anyway that is
going to do it for this one I expect
this will actually be my last dedicated
5700 XT graphics card for review that
said I will be trying to get my hands on
a few different models a few of the
cheaper models that we haven't looked at
yet for like a final roundup type video
and then that'll probably lead into like
a top 5 video ever to look at like best
value best performance all that sort of
stuff
pierre models such as as Rox challenger
Asuza stuff power colours red dragon an
msi smecker all on my list it's just a
matter of getting my hands on them now
so I can test them off here that final
roundup video oh and I also have the
sapphire pulse so sapphire pulse so I've
got that card and yeah that'll also be
included in that roundup of all other
cards I just mentioned anyway that's
gonna do it for this one if you enjoyed
this video please hit the like button
you can subscribe for more content like
this
and if you want to become more involved
with the channel get access to exclusive
discord chat take part in the monthly
live streams that team owner myself do
and Q&A is all that kind of stuff then
head over to our patreon page link is in
the video description we also have
harbor on box merch the link for that is
also in the video description anyway
above all else thank you very much for
watching I'm your host Steve and I'll
see you again next time
you
[Music]